hey guys i'm so excited for this episode
of augment now but first a big thank you
to skillshare for sponsoring this video
make sure to stick around to the end of
the episode to learn how to get a free
trial of premium membership
and to check out one of our favorite
classes but for now enjoy the episode
[Music]
how can you tell if someone is a true
marvel fan through their knowledge of
the comic books and movies
perfection is it by their collection of
marvel merchandise
maybe it's by how they dress or even if
they cosplay we brought together seven
marvel fans
one is a liar if the group discovers who
the liar is they'll win a catch prize
if the liar survives they win the cash
prize
this is odd man out
[Music]
i can do this all day that's basically
my game plan and strategy
as long as they like me and think that
i'm a marvel fan we're good i don't know
why i'm nervous because i am a marvel
fan
i need to know you do more than watch
the movies everyone watches the movies
maybe somebody who used to like marvel
and then doesn't anymore doesn't like
how the mcu is or something like that
just superhero fans in general
know a lot about even the the
superheroes that they hate as you can
see
i've turned this into a thing just a
little bit
does anyone else have any marvel tattoos
you know i hadn't got mine yet got my
tattoo
can we see it i gotta add her name to
college
but oh very nice okay just gonna put
that out there i have a
star-lord and i have rocket raccoons you
can see the bottom kind of of the
star-lord there oh nice
oh wow so jared why are you dressed up
as
cap do you cosplay him yeah i'm a
cosplayer this i can wear this suit too
i've been to several different
conventions and this is what i do for
fun
we may have ran into each other in
cosplay before jared i usually cosplay a
storm has anyone gone to any conventions
i'm from new york so i always go to
comic-con i live in london so i've gone
to the mgm comic con
oh nice are you guys more uh cinematic
uh universe fans or more of like the
comics video games
comics everything who's your guy's uh
favorite characters
who's your favorite character spider-man
which spider-man
i literally like every iteration of like
first spider-man movies
i think tom holland did the best job
because he looked like a teenager
yeah he looked like he looked like a kid
andrew garfield was too cool i think
he's so hot but like it wasn't really
spider-man
you know we don't discriminate against
anxiety in his home
so that was kind of like a geek out
round we definitely wasted a little bit
of time
i think that i'm pretty safe on
everybody's radar i felt like i had to
show my
tattoo very quickly i'm definitely going
to vote eric this round the other people
gushing about marvel stuff
eric seemed very dry about it i think
michael
he had the venom sweater but then i saw
a huge naruto rug
and i'm like maybe he's an anime fan who
knows something about marvel
i think right now i'm mostly special of
michael who i am voting off for this
round is
eric i think i'm gonna go for eric i
think i'm gonna vote for eric this round
fairchief sorry buddy and the person
eliminated this round
is eric
damn i just noticed he had a captain
america shirt
see you guys
[Music]
and this is the show and tell round also
known as the marvel
flex round you will have 10 minutes to
search and gather your most prized
marvel related merchandise
or things that really show your marvel
flex i forgot about this
how can i not show it off i mean it's
glorious get on here get this off
these boots because i like to wear my
fandom
and these are the ones that i still own
from way way back when
i was a kid should i bring my ant-man
helmet
so these are like my phil noto variant
comic book covers which are like some of
my all-time favorite things picture of
me in cosplay
i could totally use that this is harder
than i thought it would be
the reason why it's in my closet is
because i need like a proper
uv filter it's not on display because i
care too much
i'm trying to be so careful with this
right now i don't know where to put it
you don't need merch to be a marvel fan
and i feel like the amount of merch that
i have in front of me already
i can talk about okay so this is the
first thing that i want to talk about
my stanley dorbz and i got it signed
from him
how coincidental is it that we're like
recording this
on his death anniversary may he rest in
peace he's always someone i always
looked up to
he created such amazing characters and
gave hope to so many people
here's a picture that's my annoying
ex-boyfriend
i worked for an entire summer as a
superhero i carry the hammer like thor
and because of that i keep this little
myoner
and the most significant uh in that
summer i worked a lot with children and
we made diy superheroes
you know show them creativity over
conflict that's so sweet
he is wolverine uh you know his uh his
eye
i'm sorry buddy it's not wolverine it's
patch
[Laughter]
this might be kind of a cop-out but i
mean the suit right here
i bought this whenever i paid my house
off and that was a
huge deal for me i mean i achieved that
goal and then i also wanted to show off
that
i drive an ironman car
jarvis you there got yourself this is
she
throwing that out there in this yoga
proof that tony stark
has a heart this is my most prized
possession that i'm waiting for a new uv
case for
this is an original x-men 2 poster from
back when the movie came out
i was a kid this movie changed my life
there was a comic shop in town that had
this in their window
and i went in there and i was like
excuse me sir how much would it be to
buy this
and he was like i will give it to you
for free even though the bottom says not
for distribution and that you're
supposed to return it
and then here is the print so like that
i got the background of purple but that
is the star-lord
tattoo and obviously the giant
spider-man standee i yield my time
i buy like purses with the wallets
because
i would have never found them of being
able to like have any of this growing up
now i'm adult
i don't care i'm buying it chris
claremont is my favorite
writer that marvel's ever had without
him i feel like there'd be no x-men that
we know of today
so my favorite x-men story got love's
man kills
signed by chris claremont do you like
anything else in the marvel universe or
is it like just an x-men thing for you
i like the avengers they're actually no
i don't they're all they're all right
i like the avengers as far as like being
part of the story
fantastic for the avengers silver surfer
they're all very integral
important parts to marvel as a whole so
you have to be able to like like and
respect and at least read some of their
comics
to better understand the whole story arc
and the marvel universe
i am at college because of kovit they
told us we couldn't bring a lot of stuff
with me
uh so if you want this which is ah the
thing that i had to get down from my bed
the other thing that i have is this
model encyclopedia and it has
a note from stanley and i got this right
after like he passed away i have a few
inside videos at home i grew up in india
so i couldn't buy comics because they
were to a comic book store so when my
mom would travel for work
she would bring back comics for me and
that was the first one was like
spider-man so i have a encyclopedia of
that
do you read the comics too or just
because of
not being able to get access to it
mostly stick to mcu
now i don't know if you guys have like
the marvel like unlimited app or
whatever which has like so i have the
subscription for that
when the movies and stuff started coming
out i would always read the comics that
had to do with those and then especially
during like
infinity stones and all that came into
play or as they called infinity gems and
the comics like i started like reading
all of this i read all of the infinity
gauntlet
she knows that the infinity stone for
infinity gems in the comics that's a
good sign
i would have very confidently voted for
marin this round i think
until just kind of hearing her personal
story
i don't want to vote someone off who
just doesn't have the ability to have as
much
stuff as other people because like not
everybody can like nobody can afford
this crap
i'm definitely most suspicious of marin
now i understand i'm in the same
situation and want to have items that um
are very easily like
borrowed bobby a little bit suspicious
only liking x-men i'm most suspicious of
marin
i am gonna vote off michael sorry
michael
i'm going marin and the person
eliminated in this round
in round two is marin
ah i knew it i feel bad oh my gosh i'm
alive
michael looks stoked michael looks
stoked it's michael
oh you look stoked man
in in-game whenever cap gets that hammer
everybody went
nuts right and i'm going to tell you why
i didn't pick that you can't not feel
this
i am inevitable tony goes and i
am iron man he has the infinity gauntlet
he had to bring it out it's just another
chance to flex what he has
i tear up just think about it seriously
come on you can't
not love that scene so i'm gonna tell
you why i picked
the mjolnir scene jared and everybody
else cap just
grabs it and wields it and here's thor
and he's like yeah because he's always
known that
you know cap could do it or maybe
something changed between you know
then and then i'm born and raised in the
bronx new york and
stan lee is also born in the bronx new
york he went to high school in the bronx
the black panther is also one of my
favorite heroes
rest in peace chadwick and recipe
stanley at the end of infinity war
when everyone just reunited and everyone
had their last stand
you come out with the wakanda x the
bronx this is where this originated from
the bronx new york we are the ex we rep
the eggs
i don't know i think it's just a
celebration of what it is to be a marvel
fan of what it is to just be
i don't know a hero one of the ones that
i always come back to personally is the
moment in civil war when tony goes to
talk to peter
and they have that conversation without
actually having to say
with great power comes great
responsibility it's when you can do the
things i do
but you don't and then the bad things
happen they happen because
of you there's this linked guilt between
the two of them tony's feeling a lot of
guilt in that movie
every time i hear it it makes me it
makes me tear up and how he's just some
high school kid trying to do his best
and trying to do the best for his
community
so i'm gonna go outside of the mcu and
i'm going with logan
because if you're an x-meow fan if
you're a wolverine fan
you wanted to see logan go berserk or as
close as berserker as he could
we couldn't get in a pg-13 movie we
needed a raid in our movie
just giving his all to get those kids
safe
i'm sorry like
when they put the cross and they made it
an x
like i cried like a little [ __ ] in that
movie like i cried so hard
seeing him just one last time give it
his all before
he had nothing left to give was was such
a cathartic thing for a fan
i think we voted them out because
everybody here gave really good answers
but bobby's openly admitted to not
really
liking other things in the marvel
franchise it seems like bobby is just an
x-men fan
and i know obviously the x-men are
marvel for all we know there could be a
lot more dc stuff that she's just hiding
that you know obviously we would have no
idea of knowing it so i'm gonna lock in
my vote i'm just gonna vote bobby
she's got a storm tattoo i'm voting for
somebody who has a storm tattoo i'm
definitely
suspicious of michael my gut i've gotta
go with my guy i honestly
don't know bobby i can't vote for
because i really don't think it's hurt
i'm gonna go with the gut and
say michael again is the only thing i
know to do and the person
eliminated this round is
michael i know
i'm slightly concerned that it's bobby
because an x-men super fan is not
necessarily a marvel superman so i'm
like
uh i'm so sorry i voted for you i
honestly think that
we didn't need to eliminate michael mr
stark
i don't feel so good bye
if everyone feels confident that you
already caught them all
you can end the game now if the majority
has doubt
the game will continue
i think we caught them all i think we
got him i don't want to continue the
game
it's unanimous that's majority we're
going to end the game right here
i swear if it was bobby and an
x-men fan doesn't count as a marvel fan
lose my mind if the color that shows up
is green
you all win if it's red
the mole is still in the game and you
lost
in three two one
[Applause]
all these years of like marvel knowledge
finally pays off
literally excel cr guys
yes the game is over and the marvel fans
have
won that means that the four winners
will be receiving a cash prize and we're
also going to be gifting them the akintu
experience
where you'll get to pick your favorite
basics from our new interactive apparel
brand
i would like the mold to please reveal
yourself
in three two one
it was me barry i knew it i knew it
[Music]
it was too fresh i was a fan like of the
of the comics
at a young age i didn't lie about like
anything more and more or less but
like just not for me and i felt like i
connected with the dc characters a lot
more like
the sash is my favorite dc character but
you guys are so cool and i just wanted
to like talk to you guys more the entire
time i was like i just want to stay in
this game not because i don't want to
win i don't care about that i just want
to talk to these guys more
we should all continue talking i really
like you guys and i would love to geek
out
would you guys have me as well if would
you have been sure
hey good humans thank you for watching
another episode of admin out and thank
you to our sponsor
skillshare
[Applause]
i loved watching this video it's such a
fun topic and i thought our cast was
amazing but also i got kind of emotional
watching this video and just hearing
people talk about stan lee
and the black panther moment and i
almost teared up hearing bobby talk
about logan
i just i think it's so cool hearing
everyone talk about what these
characters
and these stories mean to them and
there's actually a classroom skillshare
that talks about this connection that we
develop with these heroes it's called
the art of visual storytelling by phil
jimenez who's actually a writer and
artist for marvel and dc comics
not only does he teach you how to create
a comic strip but he talks about how
these superheroes go on these
great big adventures like saving the
world and how storytelling is told
through
action but it's really all about
relationships
and how we relate to these heroes so
well because even though they have these
amazing powers
they're still very human on the inside i
would highly recommend that you take
that class or
one of the other thousands of classes
that sculpture has to offer about topics
like
writing animation film and just so many
other creative things
there are no ads on skillshare which is
amazing no interruptions when you're
learning and they're always launching
great
premium classes that you can get for
less than ten dollars a month with an
annual subscription and for the first
thousand subscribers that click the link
in the description you'll get a free
trial of skillshare's premium membership
so join skillshare develop your
creativity explore
new passions read marvel comics or maybe
dc
watch superhero movies uh or wait for
them to hopefully come to theater soon
watch jubilee videos and stay safe
everyone
bye also i'm wearing spiderman
socks right now